centre pompidou samedi 15h l'activité
redoublant ce jour j moins 2 de
l'inauguration du plus grand complexe
culturel des temps modernes il aura
fallu sept ans de recherches et de
travaux pour mener presque à son terme
le projet artistique principal du
président pompidou un musée d'art
moderne avec des salles de documentation
une vaste bibliothèque de lecture
publique ouverte aux techniques les plus
modernes est prête à accueillir les
lecteurs séduit par les trois cent mille
volumes exposé un centre de création
industrielle destinée à éclairer le
choix des consommateurs
un centre de recherche et de
coordination acoustique musique
voilà entre autres choses ce que paris
aura à sa disposition à partir de mardi
prochain tout n'est pas terminé loin de
là le centre pompidou restera jusqu'à
lundi un gigantesque chantier sur lequel
madame françoise giroud secrétaire
d'état à la culture est venu jeter un
dernier petit regard de contrôle
fresnoy la première est
bon faut que ça réussisse parce que vous
pensez que beaucoup de parisiens vont
venir est ce que ce n'est pas un petit
peu trop ce centre beaubourg ah non je
crois vraiment le plus que par curiosité
les parisiens viendront et une fois
d'être venu je crois qu'ils reviendront
je crois qu'ils recevront un coup de
froid au coeur les avis continue à être
partagés sur les qualités esthétiques de
cette bâtisse de 170 m de long sur 50 de
large les opposants parlent de
raffinerie de pétrole de monstres à
tuyaux les amateurs pour leur part
s'extasie sur l'originalité de la
réalisation reste qu'avec le centre
pompidou paris se verra doté d'une unité
artistique capable de rivaliser avec des
plus grands musées d'art moderne du
monde